yeah it was fun
um so we cyclists do on the road Joey uh
people people get so annoyed about that
um a lot of the times because some
people would um so yeah so if you didn't
know which I'm sure most you already
know uh cycle for nine days did a whole
lap of Kyushu
um let's raise money for charity and
streamed it and Chris is making a video
as well which probably won't be out this
one definitely won't be out by the time
this ass but look look out for that and
there'll be a video on my channel as
well about it if you did miss it uh but
yeah we we streamed all day every day
raising money for the IDF
congratulations man we raised 555
200 and something thousand more dollars
than we raised last time yeah that's
insane um yeah I mean it was crazy
seeing how uh everyone was just really
into it this time like it was like last
time we kind of dropped it like a week
before yeah and people were like what
like what are you cycling across why why
this is a weird stream
um but yeah people were super ready for
it time yeah we added a bit more Tech to
it we had I had a I had a Fitbit the
whole time that showed you my heart rate
and my calories burned so I thought it
was just trying to gamify it was some
stuff on screen yeah yeah
um yeah it looked like a [__] breath
of the wild Hunt it was literally like
uh you're watching a man cycling video
yeah it was like like biking simulator
yeah I wanted to bring the gaming aspect
of it the twitch is known for of course
of course and yet it went super well
um it was hard [__] hell it was so
much how would they competency to the
first cyclathon uh yeah I thought we had
tough Hills and Hokkaido and I was wrong
we had way tougher Hills oh yeah because
Q's is mad hilly yeah yeah I learned
that the hard day most days were I think
in Hokkaido we had one day that was 600
meter incline total and that was the
hottest day right and then on average I
think we had around and that was just
one day and most days I think it ended
up being around 200 300 meters of uh
incline uh that that means like over the
course of the day you would have gone up
a totally like 300 meters vertically
yeah and then probably down 300 degrees
vertically
um uh in Kyushu it was on average about
500 to 600. damn and that's like that's
a big difference that doesn't sound
crazy because we were cycling on average
anywhere between 90 to 100 kilometers a
day and that doesn't sound like a lot of
incline compared to the distance we're
doing you're basically climbing a small
Mountain every day yeah well yeah so to
for perspective the Eiffel Tower is 300
meters yeah so we would sometimes be
doing double you're basically almost
climbing like Tokyo Sky Tree every day
yeah because the Burj Khalifa is 800
meters yeah yeah so that's like you know
it's like a sky through 643 meters we
one day was 900 meters oh damn so one
day we did the Burj Khalifa and a little
bit of the Eiffel Tower on top yeah so
just for like the perspective of like
how high we would have to go up and then
go down with the distance right and so
like
the thing is is that if the incline is
kind of like you know we have like a an
incline that's like that it's like okay
well if that's an incline over 10
kilometers it's like you can do it like
it's a little bit tough but but you can
do it but the problem is is that when
you get to inclines they're like this oh
yeah you can't cycle up that like maybe
if I was in the Tour de France and like
people would dude I've got so many
annoying messages like I said I snapped
and got so angry at they were like just
use lower gear and I'm like no [__] just
losing the lower gear I you think I'd
cycled nine days and I hadn't figured
out how to [__] use my gears they say
well they sit in their games
[__] you tell me to use the lower gear
I'm in the lower ski on my bike has I
can't get up this [__]
um
and that's what it was like because we
we had a pretty like the objective was
every day is that for like generally for
safety we need to be done by Sundown
just so that we're not on the road I
don't know when it's night because like
yeah we have lights and stuff but it's
just like you can't see potholes well
you can't see stuff well I think I said
the last time we talked about it so
every day we had to be done so it was
like
some days well we would we would have
the hill right at the start and we would
have done like one fifth of the distance
over half the day right because we would
have to stop and walk for an hour just
to get over one Hill which is like a
kilometer and a half right because there
was one Hill that was I think it was a
500 meter Hill continuously and we had
to walk up all of it over two kilometers
because it was just too steep yeah uh
and then the downhill was amazing but
it's like it wastes so much time so on
top of that you're also knackered all
day you're just tired and then you gotta
you gotta do this [__] and then the
weather was so bad we had such bad
weather this time
I thought Kyushu in March was pretty
decent weather it was like kind of it's
April May and June is where it starts to
rain a lot yeah mainly May and June May
June yeah is where it gets crazy and I
thought okay if we go March we can miss
it because it won't be too cold it won't
be too hot and hopefully shouldn't be
too much rain uh day one I think we had
rain and then I think day two we didn't
have any rain uh and then day three we
didn't have rain but day four we had
like always awful torrential it was so
bad it was like Noah's Ark level rain
and it didn't stop the entire day oh my
God and
like obviously I'm not gonna like I was
complaining a lot on stream obviously I
was like [__] this [__] [__] this this
[__] sucks this is lame this [__]
because you're like you're you're
cycling and then the moment we left
um like I mean let me actually show you
a little clip just give you some context
it's raining
for cyclist to ever drown today it's
fine kind of getting wet because it's
like whatever but yeah you realize how
how [__] hot it is on your body when
you're wet for nine hours yeah like
you're actually just drenched for nine
hours and even
vessies I did not use vessels these
cycling issues the shoes get water
clogged waterlogged right away yeah so
like the the whole day even when you get
off the bike and let's say we have lunch
like we're walking around and we can't
change because like we're just you know
we're just doing it I don't even if we
did change it doesn't matter you're
gonna get wet again anyway and it wasn't
a warm day it was like 16 degrees so
you're just freezing the whole day and
the only time you feel kind of good is
when you're cycling
um because you kind of get a little bit
warm but it's like the mental fatigue
that takes on you is like insane and
then on top of that on the fourth day I
fell over like pretty badly uh we were
going pretty fast because I just wanted
to get going and then I went on to the
the pavement or the sidewalk yeah I saw
the clip yeah and they had like these
they have this stuff for blind people
um they're like these yellow lines and
they get really slippery yeah um in
there which feels like such a [__] you'd
apply for the rain they get really
slippery especially with tires I went
over it bike just [__] went under me
it's not
and so I just fell on my leg it was like
bleeding and stuff and I was like [__]
and we were only done like one third of
the day yeah
I want to do this man this sucks and I
fell over again yeah later on oh there's
somebody else safely what are they doing
why are they cycling
again God damn it again
I stopped at a light and my bike got
stuck in like where the pavement kind of
joins the road right it was kind of like
a little bit ditch and normally your
bike would be fine taking it but when
they rain it just doesn't have any grip
and it would just it just fell over and
I just went Face Forward
and then I really hurt my wrist but I I
don't again I don't want to complain
about it on streams I don't want people
to worry that I was like doing it
unsafely or anything
I mean I was fine I was doing it but it
was just tough
um but that day we raised a lot of money
yeah because people were like sorry for
me I saw like a graph of like the money
yeah there's a money raising yeah it was
like an anomaly yeah just because it was
the most depressing [__] it was so
depressing and I was like I was just on
the verge of tears because it was just
such a mentally draining day to just
have to do that and then like how did
Chris take it uh I think Chris was
powered through he was listening to
Stalin audiobooks
I think Chris was like I think I was
obviously Miserable as well for Chris
but I think Chris was just like the one
thing about that I think is kind of nice
for Chris is that if he wants to not be
on the stream and he wants to just cycle
and just listen to the audiobook or
listen to the music yeah you can just do
that which is what I think is nice
whereas I always have to think about
like all right the strain The Strain The
Strain
um as well as obviously you know cycling
um and that was a and another tough
thing that comes to the Rain which is
like the pretty the it's like they're
both equally as frustrating as it the
the like the tech that we're using does
not want to get wet at all and so like
we have to use like weird ass water
coverings and that's a problem because
that overheats everything yeah yeah so
halfway through the day like I couldn't
check my phone or anything so I was
streaming without seeing the chat or any
of the donations so I I for like the
last two hours I couldn't see anything I
don't know if we had signal I don't know
if the stream was working my bag was
getting soaked which is worrying because
then even though I had a water cover for
it the electronics the electronics it
was like it wasn't doing anything
because the rain was so bad and we were
in it for so long that yeah it was like
it didn't matter the water was getting
through somehow and so you're like oh my
God I can't see chat this equipment
might be broken I don't even know if
it's working it might not even survive
to the next day and then I can't see the
phone I can't see anything and I'm just
kind of talking to the camera and half
the time I wasn't even talking so I was
just so like miserable and sad that I
couldn't see anything and I had to go up
a [__] Hill in the rain it was so
[__] I hated it all and that was like a
day where I just like the next day I was
like I can't believe I have to get back
on the bike yeah that was like horrible
um and like my leg was also like my leg
was swollen because I'd fallen on it
pretty badly yeah and it was all it was
still kind of bleeding and stuff but I
mean it was like kind of stinging but it
was like fine to cycle on and luckily
the next day thank God it was sunny and
it was like felt like a oh my god there
was a God
God smiled down I'm gonna be religious
because I just feel like if there was
another rainy day after that I think I
would have lost it yeah yeah and for the
rest of the the the kind of cycle we
didn't really have any terrible weather
it's kind of like we'd get a little bit
of rain for an hour it would stop yeah
it'd be a little bit of rain maybe the
clouds would come in we never really had
sunny days we'd like one day where it
was sunny which kind of sucked because
Hokkaido is pretty much all clear skies
until yeah in a few days it sucked but I
mean obviously you shouldn't cycle in
that weather normally yeah honestly if
we were smart we would have planned it
so we could just be like nope no cycling
today but it looks like a break day but
also I feel like the kind of the the
morale of it is like and the whole like
reason that I think the viewers my mind
it's like this my weird stream of mine
like it's like you you do it through the
good and the bad times right yeah yeah
that's what makes it like well that's
the adventure right yeah well that's
that's why on that day people donated
like I think like last day you know and
yeah congrats man yeah and that was a
miserable day as well because Chris
insisted do we go to McDonald's and I
was still wet and cold and I was like
can we take it to go because she's like
no no let's eat inside and I was like
fine so I'm in this McDonald's I'm
soaking wet and I'm just eating
cheeseburgers and my leg is bleeding and
I'm like what the [__] I just want to go
back to the [__] let's just get out
of here I don't want to be in this with
a 40 minute drive to the airbnbs the one
that was the of course the day where I
wanted to get back quickest yeah one day
where the drive was super far away yeah
because we were in the middle of nowhere
in uh kyushi it was like yeah we're like
a place called Izumi which is like a
town that has like one hotel and it was
fully booked so we had to drive 30
minutes into some like Villa and it was
very nice but it was like just like you
were like come on by the time I finally
managed to get a bath it was like 9 p.m
and I was soaked the whole day and I was
I was like shaking and freezing it was
miserable
um but yeah I was really glad I did it
holy [__] was it hard it was hard it was
hard you gonna do another one I don't
know we'll see
like I think I think I would like to do
another one but I want to think about
how I can maybe mix it up a little bit
more yeah yeah yeah I think there's a
I'm gonna cycle
oh my God
having a scooter call me not yeah